MATT GAUNT: We're now going to
do the Material Design Panel.
Come on.
Jake should be here
to introduce me,
but he got pulled
into a HR meeting.
That could either
be great or his kind
of subtle hints of a promo
or fire may have gone sour.
So if you could go cross
your fingers for him.
I mean, I've seen his work.
I'm kind of assuming I'm
never going to see him again.
So, yeah, Material
Design and the Web.
That's what we're going
to be talking about.
Now, I have a slight confession.
Jake's said like
Pauls do performance.
I think I landed
this not for being
like Doug Designer, but
just Matt Material Design.
They were scraping
the barrel a bit.
Because I'm essentially
kind of a design noob.
That's how I describe myself.
But I'm obviously working
with the material design team
with Web Starter Kit.
And I used to do a lot of
native app development.
And it's interesting,
the culture there,
because you're really
strongly encouraged.
Like you follow the
design guidelines
that these native
platforms define.
And it makes a lot of sense.
Users get to this point where
they know what they're doing
and know what to expect.
So I find material design really
interesting from that point
of view.
So on the panel,
we have Zach, who
is one of our
material design team.
You work on Android
and Polymer, I believe.
ZACH GIBSON: Yeah, both things.
MATT GAUNT: We have my
doppelganger, Rob Dobson,
US version of me.
He works on Polymer as
well, all the design.
Then we have Josh, he's one of
our staff software engineers.
I'm told he fixes all
the things for everyone.
JOSH ESTELLE: That's
a slight exaggeration.
MATT GAUNT: It's not.
We have Roma Shah.
Roma is the one who basically
made all the awesome theme
color stuff in
Chrome, as well as
the integration with recents.
Tons of cool stuff.
And then we have Paul Lewis.
PAUL LEWIS: Hello.
MATT GAUNT: Who is
a performance wonk.
But he actually has an amazing
flair for design an animation.
You wouldn't expect it
from looking at him.
PAUL LEWIS: No, you
really wouldn't.
Hidden talents.
ROB DOBSON: [INAUDIBLE]
MATT GAUNT: You may
not have heard that,
but Rob just actually had
a really quite harsh dig.
You should feel bad about that.
PAUL LEWIS: At me?
I hope not, Rob.
Or Matt, whichever one you are.
MATT GAUNT: Ha, ha.
So the first thing
I want to say,
if you've got a question that
you actually want to ask anyone
on the panel, please
do go to the mic.
I will be looking at that
mic desperately hard.
If no one is standing
there, I might cry.
But you can also
tweet @ChromiumDev
and we will be getting
all of this through.
And I'll ask them as
we're going along.
I have to call out
Rahal, who actually asked
a question on the panel going,
Polymer is very heavyweight,
like hundreds of kilobytes.
If you just want to use material
design styling behavior,
are you working on
addressing this?
What can we expect?
And then after the
Polymer panels,
he very kindly went in and added
a comment, never mind, I guess.
So thank you very much
for asking the question
then, B, commenting afterwards.
So first genuine question
is from Rachel Nabbers.
And I really like this
because she describes herself
as an animation wonk.
I love seeing Google putting
animation front and center
in material design
documentation.
How would you suggest other
UXes and designers prioritize
animation at their companies.
Or rather, why was it
a priority for Google?
And I'm going to consult a bit
of a wider question of like,
what kind of made Google
realize that it needed
this strong design guideline?
I'm guessing Zach?
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah.
So a lot of the way that we've
been thinking about design
right now is that it's no longer
important to just think screen
by screen.
In that we have
to really consider
how you get from
screen to screen.
So when we're doing a lot
of wireframes and UX design,
we're constantly trying
to draw the screens
in between what
we'd normally do.
And because it's the
consistency in our animation
that makes us feel like we're
in a familiar environment.
And that if we're doing motion
right, we, our users and us,
we can kind of predict the
future of like where things
will go when I touch something.
So it's really important that
we're consistent with motion
and not overdoing it,
which we get a lot.
MATT GAUNT: So it's funny
that you mentioned that.
Because Ashuana S.,
from Mountain View,
they asked a question
that essentially that
was I'm going to basically
get the gist of it too.
Given all the animations
in material design,
they look great.
Like no one argues that.
And when you first using
it, it's really nice.
Eventually though, some people
may find that they dislike them
because it's getting in the way.
So they were actually
suggesting like the idea
of having a novice
and advance mode.
Like you've seen it,
you like it, cool.
But, eh, get out of the way,
ZACHARY GIBSON:
Yeah, I don't think
anyone disagrees
that we need to be
catering to what our users want.
Whether it's slower animations
or faster animations
or no animations.
I think that's a valuable
criticism that we're definitely
taking and thinking about.
And Roma?
ROMA SHAH: One thing
I would say in terms
of do we want to have different
toggles for novice users
or advanced users.
I think what we need to do is
just evolve the specs to make
animations work better
for most people.
And have the right
defaults, basically.
I think one thing
that we try to do
is simplify things and not
make it so that users are now
with the burden and the
onus of figuring out
what works for them.
Like we want to help
people out with that.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah.
And the spec is not a
finished things by any mean.
And I think we're constantly
refining it, and working it,
and making things better,
and faster, and more smooth
as well.
ROMA SHAH: And I'll just to
add to that one more thing.
That we are continuing
to work on desktop more.
Zach is actually doing
a lot of this work.
But a lot of the
things that you see
in motion on phones, in
tablets, make a lot of sense
because you have a
smaller real estate.
Things are moving
a shorter distance.
And those don't
necessarily translate well
to bigger screens.
And so we are
keeping that in mind
and trying to figure out
what works across devices.
One animation or transition
doesn't necessarily
work from phone to
like a 30 inch monitor.
MATT GAUNT: Live question, go.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So yesterday, Roma,
during her presentation,
spoke to the little
callout circle.
That you should only ever
have one and sometimes none.
What if I have two main things?
Like if I have a slide show,
I'm going back and forward.
Is it ever OK to put
two of them on there?
And what is the reasoning
behind only having one?
MATT GAUNT: That's actually
a really good question.
I just remember, I was
at an android event.
Someone at literally
materialized their app.
And they literally had the
exact same thing, two callouts.
And it was kind of like, well do
they live up to the top or do I
put one at the top,
down at the bottom.
And yeah, it's a fair thing.
You kind of want to
tweak a little bit.
So yeah.
ZACHARY GIBSON:
Yeah I think you're
talking about what we call
the floating action button.
And it's something
that we see-- the way
that we describe is that
it should encapsulate
the hallmark of what
your application does.
And maybe it's not
application based,
but it's contextual to
whatever screen or thing
that you're doing.
So we feel that having one
gives our users less decisions
to make and is ultimately a
better thing for our users.
And it also challenges us
as designers and developers
to make decisions about what
our apps should be doing,
and what their
purpose is, and trying
to boil that down
into one thing.
Obviously, you can't always
get it down to one thing.
And like, Google Maps has two.
So I think that
what we're saying
is that we're trying
to boil things
down to a foundation that
are our recommendations.
And if those aren't working,
I don't think anyone
on our team is
striking down them
as spec, as a policing
type thing too much.
Hopefully not too much.
But I think that
we're just trying
to make the best
recommendations to build
a really strong foundation for
all the stuff that we're doing.
MATT GAUNT: So got a
little bit of beef.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: So you kind of
said like it's evolving.
And the material
design side, it kind of
feels like its concrete.
It's kind of like, here it
is, it's done, like boom.
You've said it's not,
and it's evolving.
But how?
If I were to implement it
or I wanted to follow it,
how do I stay up to date
with what's changed?
And also, how do I figure
out what's changed?
Like even if you just
tweaked it and said,
actually we've updated the spec.
Like you need to know
what parts have changed.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Sure.
JOSH ESTELLE: So the spec
is definitely evolving.
Right now the couple times
we've made big changes,
I think we've done announcements
on the Google Design Twitter
and on the Google Design+ page.
One thing we're working
on that's not quite
where we want to be, but is
to have more of a change log,
diff, of like here's
what changed in the spec
to have that be really
explicit and really clear.
We know the spec needs an
easier way to search it too.
So there's things coming
just for our own tools
and how we're communicating
this out that we think
will get better.
And will help communicate
some of these things.
ZACHARY GIBSON:
And just to add, I
think we'd be in
a worse situation
if we were saying, all right.
It's done.
We've solved it.
Because everything is
constantly changing.
And people are taking the
foundation that we've built
and doing really innovative
things on top of it.
And that is defining
new patterns and things
about how we're using
our applications.
And so we need to embrace that.
Otherwise, it's going to
be obsolete before we know.
JOSH ESTELLE: A lot of
the changes too come
in the form of additions.
So they're there
hasn't been too much in
like, we thought something
would be this way,
but now it's this way.
It's more, we thought
something was this way.
But then someone
asked about what
about this thing, this thing,
and that thing that are all
related but we didn't
actually cover before.
So a lot of the things
that we change in spec
are really adding
more clarification
to things that weren't specced
out as completely or fully
as we originally wanted to.
MATT GAUNT: I have a question.
AUDIENCE: So Polymer
material design
itself is very
opinionated In the sense
that there's specify breakpoints
that have been cited on.
Do these breakpoints
correlate to Android as well?
And what's the
decisions behind them?
Is it metrics based
or why, basically?
ROB DOBSON: Yeah,
my understanding
is that the
breakpoints follow what
are the breakpoints
inside the spec.
The spec has a kind
of grid that tells you
the spacing for everything.
And we've just tried
to adhere to that
with our own breakpoints.
Having said that,
those breakpoints
can be configured if it's
not quite working for you.
You know, if you feel
like maybe you need,
for instance, for
the drawer panel.
You want the drawer panel to
come out at a different time.
Perhaps it's making
your content look
weird at the current breakpoint.
You can always set that with
responsive width or something
like that.
So some of these you should
be able to configure yourself.
MATT GAUNT: Does material spec
actually define breakpoints?
ROB DOBSON: I'm not
100% sure on that.
I would have to ask Frankie.
I don't know.
Zach, do you know?
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah, no.
MATT GAUNT: So Polymer--
ZACHARY GIBSON:
It's something that
is like, literally
before I walked in,
I am working on that right now.
So I think that how we
handle responsive design,
and how our applications
and websites adapt
to different screens
is in progress.
And we're just working on a
system right now that's just,
we're refining it, we're trying
to build responsive components,
and things that work
better crossover
huge variety of screen sizes.
So I don't think
it's solved yet.
ROB DOBSON: I should
clarify, actually
now that I think about it.
The only components that I
think even have breakpoints
are core drawer panel
and core scaffold, right?
Is there another one they
were using that had it?
Yeah, those are the two.
And I think those
breakpoints were decided on
based on as we were building
some of the material samples
internally.
We were like this looks like
about where it needs to break.
And perhaps that's where
we came up with it.
JOSH ESTELLE: So then that's
why we need Zach's work.
So it's not just everybody
thinking this is about right.
PAUL LEWIS: But
that's OK, right?
If somebody knows their app
well enough, they can be like,
this doesn't look right
when it's like this.
I should have the freedom
as the designer/developer
to kind of go in another
100 pixels is good by me.
JOSH ESTELLE: Right,
but the point I'm making
is that if you're just not sure.
If you're just
like, I don't know
where I should
put my breakpoint.
Then following the spec
is a huge advantage.
To just being
like, OK, someone's
probably thought about
this more than I want.
PAUL LEWIS: Your
sensible defaults, right?
And then from there you
get to kind of go off road
if you think you
know the way better.
MATT GAUNT: Nice metaphor, Paul.
And I don't want to cut
this conversation off,
but literary this question has
come in on Twitter, though.
No, [? anthemchris ?] says,
do any variation slash options
exist of material design?
Or is it case of one
size fits all philosophy?
And by the sounds of it, no
it's not one size fit all.
Is that not fair to say?
ROMA SHAH: Yeah,
we were actually
talking about this a lot
yesterday at the booth.
But material design
is a system, right?
And there are some things
that if you take them
outside of the system
and use them one off.
Like for example, there's three
different types of buttons.
There's a button
that looks like text,
it has absolutely
nothing around it.
There's a floating button that
it's encased in something,
and it's like
popped off the page.
And then there's the
floating action button.
But if you take
that one button that
is literally capitalized text
with nothing encasing it.
And say like, I'm
going to go off
and do my own thing with this.
And not follow
where in the spec we
say this is probably where
this make sense to go.
You should probably
stick to that.
There are some cases
where things will just
break if you just kind of
go and use them randomly,
but there's also a
lot of flexibility
in the material design spec.
I would say in terms of
structure, and app layout,
and like so many different
things that you could--
you know, who was asking about
the floating action button?
Like that's one thing
where we are probably
more strongly saying you should
have one thing everywhere.
But obviously, there's always
going to be room to have
to have flexibility based on
the complexities of your app
and stuff that we cannot
possibly upfront consider just
sitting in our
offices at Google.
MATT GAUNT: Nope,
that's all fair.
So the next question I'm
going to ask is interesting.
So it's from
[? Francis Berman. ?]
It sounds like there's an
interest material design being
best practice for some UIs.
How are design patterns being
validated, i.e., user tested?
And what are the
implications of encouraging
wide, non-Google
adoption of material?
So the first part
of that I guess
is what are doing
for user testing.
And then second part
is kind of what is,
let's say everyone's
using material.
What is the result of that?
Who wants to go?
JOSH ESTELLE: I'll
talk about user
testing a little bit first.
So we have a user
experience research team
that's worked on material
design from the beginning.
And they've user tested
all sorts of pieces,
sort of early in
the design process
and later in the design process.
And that's definitely influenced
some of the decisions.
There are probably
things that we still
need to do more testing on.
So I won't say that everything
has been perfectly tested
and it's perfect.
Because it's
probably not, right?
That's to the point of
how a lot of this stuff
is still going to be
changing and iterating.
We also have been working with
all of the Google products
that are implementing
material design.
And they have their own UX
testing and their own metrics.
So maybe in their first version
where they launched something
using some material
design concept,
they might collect a
bunch of data for us,
collect a bunch of metrics.
And tell us that, we tried
this thing you had in spec,
but our click through rate
on this thing dropped a lot.
And that'll give us something
to take back to our design team
and recheck over those things.
So we're both doing it on
those kind of smaller scale UX
studies and on the larger
scale metrics collected
at the product level.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah,
the second part.
We get the question
a lot of where
is my brand if I
follow this back.
And we've been reviewing a ton
of third party Android apps
right now.
And it's really, it's
actually like so much
more exciting to see
how people are injecting
their brand into
their apps right now.
Because we're no longer
saying, at least on Android,
like your logo is
this big, and it's
on the top left
corner in the toolbar.
We're saying like, we're
leaving a little more open.
It's flexible.
You can express your brand
through color, through content,
through the way that you talk
about things in your app.
And there are
other opportunities
for just like big, bold, brand
decisions that are not just
like a 50, 60 dip
thing in the corner.
And so I think there are
definitely aspects of it
that like there
are similarities.
And in those similarities,
like I said in the beginning,
our users know where things are.
And they know how things will
react when they touch them.
And they know where certain
things will bring them
after they interact with them.
And it's through those
patterns that people are just
learning about how to just whip
through the internet quicker.
MATT GAUNT: And I guess
there's a little bit
of a dark art to it, right?
Because if you've got your
brand, you have a design team.
They always want to get certain
things across to their user.
To then apply that to something
else, it is kind of a fine art.
That's always the
impression I've
got from any of the
designers I've worked with.
So [? Francis Berman ?] has
also asked the next question.
And this is right about when
it went a little bit Jerry
Springer during
the Polymer talk.
When Alice was just
like, accessibility what?
What's going on with
focus states and stuff
like that in material?
So [? Francis Berman ?]
asked, what's
materials approach for
accessibility support?
Silence.
JOSH ESTELLE: We should
have accessibility support.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah.
Yeah, totally.
MATT GAUNT: That was easy.
ZACHARY GIBSON: I
mean, I don't think
anybody is saying that we don't
want accessibility standards.
Obviously, when our
goal is to organize
the world's information
for everyone,
everyone is included in that.
And I think that we
are doing our best to--
and maybe it's not
totally apparent yet--
but we're doing our
best to make everything
that we're doing accessible
and work for everyone.
JOSH ESTELLE: It's worth
noting somethings have already
been worked on a lot.
Like part of the
stuff behind the color
palette and some of the
suggested colors for typography
are directly aligned to
accessibility contrast ratios.
And we've thought
about those a lot.
So a lot of that's
gone into there.
Some of the things
like focus states
are things that we need to
spend a little more time on.
We haven't completely
figured out
how that should work to hit
all the accessibility angles we
want to hit and also
fit within the design.
MATT GAUNT: So one of the things
I was is going to add to that.
I'm moderator, I can
say whatever I want.
So in the Web
Starter Kit project,
we've already-- like
I said in the talk
yesterday-- we've been
working the material design
team to bring in stuff
that's just not there.
We're pretty much
already hitting
the accessibility stuff.
Because obviously,
like Addy Osmani.
He's working on the project.
He knows what the
Polymer team is
going through with all of this.
And we're going to get
to that point as well.
Where we're going
to go, hey, we've
done this kind of like
materials design style guide.
And we've also go
keyboard support.
But what do we do with that now?
Because we're ready to go
ahead and style that stuff,
but what do we do?
So I think there's going to be a
point where if it's not clearly
defined, it's going to
be one of these things
where each project's going
to start kicking people.
Until then, people are probably
already building it in.
But they're doing
their own thing
and it's just not standardized.
ZACHARY GIBSON:
Yeah, I definitely
agree that standardizing
is beneficial.
In progress.
MATT GAUNT: I've got
so many questions here.
No one live, damn it.
So the next question
I'm going ask.
And this is from
sil, but I'm assuming
that's Stuart Langridge,
because I follow him on Twitter.
But basically his
question is saying,
if you work on a
native platform,
you're kind of encouraged
to follow certain design
guidelines.
And one of the really
big Anti-Patterns
you can just never follow is
like, don't take an iOS app
and then just move
it onto Android.
That's seen as a
massive Anti-Pattern.
So why is it that
material design
can be pitched as
this kind of one size
fits all in terms of
just design language
across different platforms?
And is that something that
we should encourage or not?
And then is there any problem
with doing the reverse?
Like taking some like
metro and moving that
onto Android and the web.
So it's kind of, yeah, it's
an interesting question.
Because it isn't
massive Anti-Pattern
within some communities,
and yet material design
is kind of like the opposite.
JOSH ESTELLE: I would say
something some of those
are Anti-Patterns because those
design guidelines were baked
in an environment
for a specific thing.
Like most the iOS
design guidelines
are kind of specific
to mobile platform.
Where a lot of the things we've
tried to do for material design
is really taking
a broader approach
to trying to design
across mobile and desktop
all at the same time.
We haven't hit all
those things we need it,
but it's coming at that
from a broad angle.
So I think that helps make it
apply more across the board
than just taking something
that was designed for one thing
and putting it somewhere else.
We're trying to design
something that's really
designed for all things,
and help give people
guidelines to design your own
apps with that perspective.
So when you're designing
an app, you're not
designing your mobile app,
and then thinking like,
oh how do I make a
website out of this?
You're designing one app
that works well on a phone
and works well on a big monitor,
and everywhere in between.
MATT GAUNT: So
[? Francis Berman ?]
has come back with
another question.
You cheeky little pebble.
So why wasn't accessibility
a priority at the start?
Now I think that's
already unfair.
Because we heard
from the Polymer team
that there was like a blinking
thing involved, or pulsating.
So it sounded like it was
thought from the start.
At least, I hope it was.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah,
it definitely was.
And sometimes, when doing
things in design first,
we push things a little
too far sometimes.
Which is like--
MATT GAUNT: You have
too much coffee.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah,
we have too much coffee,
whatever it is.
And I think that is how
people should be designing.
Is to say, let's keep pushing
this further, and further,
and further.
And sometimes you make decisions
that are, in that process,
not accessible.
And so then it's like, OK,
where do we start to step back?
How do we reign
this in a little bit
to make sure that
everyone can use it?
JOSH ESTELLE: I would
say accessibility
was a priority at
the start and--
ZACHARY GIBSON: Definitely.
JOSH ESTELLE: --has been an
important priority through.
I think focus states are an
example of something that
weren't prioritized as much
early on because we were
focusing on more towards mobile
and to touch interfaces, where
focus states are
just less important.
Moving towards the
web and keyboards,
then focus states are
much more important.
And that's why they've probably
come a little bit later.
MATT GAUNT: That's
fair enough, I think.
So we have a question
from someone called Pete.
What lessons have
you learned from apps
that you've currently
switch to material?
I'm going to start
with Mr. Lewis
because you've been
awfully quiet, sir.
PAUL LEWIS: That is because
I am feeling rather unwell.
Do forgive me, folks.
It's remarkable--
MATT GAUNT: If
you've got to run.
PAUL LEWIS: If I've got
to run, don't judge me.
It's just remarkable.
I think jet lag.
So I had the
challenge, I suppose,
of taking the Chrome Dev Summit
site that I did last year
and materializing it.
And it's really hard
because it's a content site.
And the spec doesn't say
much about content sites.
And so you look at it, and it
kind of goes, I'm material.
But at the same time, I probably
got loads of things wrong.
And so the challenges?
I don't know.
It's to put in from the people
who do know material better
than you and ask them.
And I'm in a fortunate
position that I
can ask people who worked
on material and say,
is this wrong?
And they go, yes it is.
And then you try and
fix it as best you can.
You try and make it make sense.
And I hope I've
struck that balance.
I did follow the keylines.
And so you're
trying, in my case,
I think it's like there
are some immutables.
Like the keylines,
the contrast ratios,
the things that
you should make it
feel material, even
if you go and make
other mistakes or changes.
And there are the things that I
think you have the flexibility.
And you should take
advantage of the flexibility
and try and just make
it work for the thing
that you're building.
So that's probably
the thing I learned
with it is, it's not immutable.
It's flexible.
You just have to be the right
kind of flexible with it.
ROB DOBSON: Yeah, I'll
sort of second that.
In particular, there's
some immutable parts,
as Paul was saying,
that are really nice.
When I did the first
pass at the contacts app.
I sent it Zach.
And then Zach was like,
there's a lot of things in here
that we have in
the don't column.
And I was like, OK, OK.
And he's like
follow the keylines.
And the keylines, for those
of you who don't know,
they're just the guidelines.
Basically saying, we have these
things that are like 8 dip
apart or whatever, or
16 dip or whatever.
And it's really,
really, really nice
because they start
answering questions for you.
Like you're looking
at your thing.
And you're like, how far is this
things supposed to be apart?
And then you're just
like, oh yeah, OK.
8 dip, 8 dip, 16 dip, whatever.
And it's really nice because
then just rationalizing
how you should structure
your page and everything
becomes very simple.
And it becomes very clean.
And your design just
starts to unify itself.
So I actually really
like the guidance
that's there in the materials.
PAUL LEWIS: When you
look at the don'ts.
I mean, I look at the don'ts,
and I'm like, ooo, that's ugly.
It's like it's trying to
do the material thing,
but it looks so wrong.
And the don'ts are just as
helpful as the dos for me.
Because often when you look
at something, you're like, OK,
I get you what you
mean in this context.
But the don'ts kind of
give you the Anti-Patterns.
They give you the context
of the things you definitely
should not do.
And when you look at
them, you go, yeah,
I see why I shouldn't
do that visually.
At least, I hope.
I mean, that's
helpful for me anyway.
ROMA SHAH: Zach is
actually working
on more grids and layouts
for content oriented sites
verses like very appy sites.
ZACHARY GIBSON: It's too late.
It's coming.
PAUL LEWIS: Next year, I get it.
ZACHARY GIBSON: No, I mean
when you work on mobile first,
something has to come second.
So every everything
has been in flight.
And we've been thinking
about things all along
and how it scales.
But especially when we're
focusing so much focus
on the apps, content sites
like have come second.
And we're working on
that stuff constantly.
And getting back to just the
responsive grid solutions.
Like it's included in
that content sites.
PAUL LEWIS: I mean, you can.
I mean the material spec site is
a site and it looks materially.
There are clues there.
It may be more work than
perhaps I would have liked,
but that's not to
say you can't do it.
I don't believe it's impossible.
And like you say,
you're working on it.
So I'm high-fiving
from over here.
ZACHARY GIBSON: I think
what we're doing right now
is that the grid
that's on the spec site
is a very simple grid.
And there's a very
simple logic to it.
And what we're
trying to do is run
a lot of different
types of content
through it to see
how it holds up.
And see where we
need to revise it
and turn it into something
that we can use systematically.
MATT GAUNT: And it should
be quite fun because then I
can steal all of his hard work,
stick it in Web Starter Kit,
and steal all the glory.
No.
ZACHARY GIBSON: What
we're trying to do
is just build a really strong on
foundation for all this stuff.
I keep saying it.
But if we have that really
strong foundation, and tools
to help us get to that
strong foundation,
then we don't have
to think about things
like how big should
make this type?
How far should I put this thing
from the edge of the screen?
What should happen when
I touch this thing?
And we can think about
other, bigger, things
like why are people
using our apps?
What should they
be using them for?
And what's next.
MATT GAUNT: So Roma,
I was kind of hoping
you'd jump into some the stuff
you've been doing with Chrome.
Because in my head,
the whole change
of Chrome around when
material design came out.
Like Chrome now compared
to what used to be
is actually pretty different.
And in my head, I
was like how do you
approach materializing Chrome?
Because ultimately material
can be in the web and Chrome
for Android is on a
thing that is material.
And you're trying to
materialize the thing that
sat right in the middle.
So do you any input on what
the hell happened there?
Like the process?
ROMA SHAH: Yeah.
So I mean, I touched on
this a little bit yesterday.
But we don't think of
Chrome as an individual app,
like a single app, right?
It's a platform,
as a meta platform
within other platforms.
And we're there for
other people's content.
So the idea that we would
have a very material toolbar
and then right below it
would be a material toolbar
was like a little
too meta for us.
So I think that we have taken a
lot of the material principles
and applied it to things
like pre L for Chrome
for Android that still
has its own tab switcher
and stuff like that.
We have taken a spin on
material in the sense
of trying to give
developers the ability
to give theme color
to their toolbar.
And like materialize the Chrome
parts of things for themselves.
It's kind of desire.
MATT GAUNT: You actually went to
level more meta than I actually
had considered.
ROMA SHAH: One of the things
that we're thinking about
is what we do on desktop.
So the easiest thing
for us to think about
is how to materialize the
content UI that we have.
Like bookmarks, and
settings, and history,
and all those things.
But we still actually
haven't quite
figured out what to do
for things like desktop.
Or things where we have this
like very, very old school
metaphor of tabs, you know.
Which basically the
material design spec
doesn't cover a
lot of the things
that we do because we're
so weird and different.
So we have to kind of figure
out where we do fit in there.
The other thing that we--
ZACHARY GIBSON: I
just want to say,
I bet that applies to
a lot of the ideas that
are floating around.
That maybe we can't find the
specific thing in spec that
relates exactly to what
we're trying to redo.
But I think what's most
exciting about all this stuff is
that, everyone is
rethinking what exists.
And saying, how do
we do this better?
And even if not like-- even
if the icon is 25 dip instead
of 24 dip, it's still
challenging what exists
and trying to make
things better.
And I think that's the
really exciting part
about all of this.
ROMA SHAH: One of
the things that's
come up that's resonated
with me because we've
thought a lot about
this on the Chrome team
is like, we are on a bunch
of different platforms.
We're on OS X, Windows,
Linux, iOS, Android.
And because we're the
container for other apps,
we have to figure out
what the right balance is
between being consistent
across all our platforms
and also fitting into the
platforms in a way that doesn't
make us stand out
more than we want to.
MATT GAUNT: That
all sounds fair.
So meta.
Live question.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, I don't
think this happens
enough in the industry.
But I just want to say
props to the material team.
I think it looks phenomenal.
And you know, I think Google
has got a lot of flack
in he past for not
having enough design.
So just, I think,
really great job.
So thanks for all the work
that you guys have done.
It really is beautiful.
My question is
more around how do
you see the process for
these kind of-- you know,
Paul, he did a lot of work
for some custom elements.
How do you see that involving
to getting to a point
where maybe they
become paper elements.
And then maybe somehow get
into the specs somewhere.
What is that process?
Do you see a [INAUDIBLE] request
happening in GitHub on Polymer,
or?
I'm just kind of curious how you
see new elements and new things
coming in from the community?
ROB DOBSON: Yeah, I mean, right
know there are still actually
parts of the spec that
we haven't implemented.
There's like certain
kinds of containers.
One thing that people bring
up a lot is, they're like,
where's the card?
How come you don't
just have a card?
Like that's all over the spec.
And I'm like, eh.
And I ask the team all the
time, can we have a card?
And they're like it's just--
PAUL LEWIS: I can
give you a card now.
ROB DOBSON: Yeah?
PAUL LEWIS: Now you want
to Polymerize my stuff?
ZACHARY GIBSON: Well we
have a card, actually,
but it's hidden.
It's in Polymer Labs.
MATT GAUNT: What?
ROB DOBSON: Yeah,
it's swipeable card.
It's in Polymer Labs
or something that.
But it's hidden.
But I want that to get promoted.
I want that to be an
official paper element.
So, yeah.
There's some stuff that
actually is still in the spec
that we have not pulled in yet.
As far as an external pull
request for that, I don't know.
That's not something that I
guess we haven't-- I don't know
if we've even seen any yet.
Someone being like,
here is a paper element,
I made it for you.
I guess we'd be open to it.
I mean, we do everything
out in the open.
And if it follows the spec, and
it's something that's missing,
that would be pretty cool.
But yeah, I guess we
haven't even seen that yet.
But if there's something
that the team is working on
that they want us to build, we
sit like next to each other.
So they just can tell us
and then we add it that way.
JOSH ESTELLE:
We've interestingly
seen this even
just within Google.
So the Polymer guys are
building their stuff.
But there's other teams
building on other frameworks
within Google, and they've
built different variants.
And some people come along
and they're like, oh,
nobody built this thing.
And so even just
within the company,
we're working a lot with
these different teams
to do things such that
they're following spec,
if it is outlined in spec.
And if it's not
outlined in spec,
we're trying to get them
in touch with designers.
Now that doesn't scale
to the whole world,
to all the third party stuff.
But we've seen that happen
a little bit externally
with our icons.
So we released the set of
all the material icons.
And I feel like the day after we
released it, someone popped up.
Like a totally third
party, unrelated site,
but it had all of our icons.
And then they were
already making
like community
contributions to that
of icons done in our style.
And that's something that's
really interesting and exciting
to me.
To see how we can leverage
the whole community
to contribute to these things.
I do think it's a challenging
organizational problem
to keep the quality
and the to specness
of things, where
we want it to be.
But I think it's something
interesting for us to look at.
MATT GAUNT: One thing
that was in your question
that I don't think was answered.
So what happens if someone
wanted to add something?
Like say they felt
that something
was missing in the spec and they
wanted to actually add that in?
How does that look
internally and it
could be made to work
externally as well?
ZACHARY GIBSON: I don't know.
MATT GAUNT: I'll
take that as a no.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah.
I mean, we're currently
doing a lot of app reviews.
And those are both third
party reviews and internal app
reviews.
And there are a
lot of stuff that
comes from those app reviews.
Like we do need to think
about pagination or something.
Maybe we need to get that in.
And I don't know, there's
a lot of communities
that we all follow.
Like the Google design
Twitter and G+ and all the dev
relations like stuff
that's happening.
Like where we're watching
and in a non creepy way.
JOSH ESTELLE: With a
lot of it, just do it.
Like if you think there's an
article missing from the spec,
write the article and put it
on your blog, put it somewhere.
And get the attention around it.
And if the people latch
onto it, we'll see it.
And I think that's--
The same thing with like, say
you build some new component.
Just built it, creative
it, put it out there.
Let people use it.
And I think that
contributes back
to the whole
community doing this.
MATT GAUNT: And
there was actually--
this is something that happened
in the Android community.
Because you had the nav
drawer coming from the side.
And basically there was a
ton of third party libraries.
And Google didn't
actually have a voice
of whether to do it or not.
And it was kind of
frustrating to watch
the community basically try
and do different things.
And it got even worse
because each Google product
had a slightly different
version of the drawer.
And everyone was like, oh, I've
done a library for this one,
I've done a library
for that one.
And it was kind of frustrating.
But eventually, the
fact the community
latched on to these libraries
and were literally like look,
this is actually a navigation
pattern that works for us,
and users seem to like it.
We listened and then we
just went and did it.
I don't like how long
it took us to do it.
I'd say that.
But it happened.
So it could easily be like that.
I also really like the
analogy that someone still, I
think some of our products.
And they literally
took a nav drawer
and went here's
the different ways
that they do it in
different products.
And this is great because if
you have to sell something
to a client, you pick
one, and then use
this as an actual guide for it.
And validate it that way.
That's bad.
So we should fix that.
But yeah, thank you
for your question.
So this is from Roman Nurik.
He's on the dev rel design team.
Since material design
is focused on touch,
should anything change
when designing primarily
for keyboard and mice?
And I'm going to open it up to
TVs as well, because why not?
Keypad.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yes.
Our stuff should
adapt to the way
that our users are using them.
We do try and keep a lot
of stuff similar though.
The Chromebook pixel
is a touch screen
so it should have minimum
touch targets that
are the same as any
other touchscreen.
And I think with
those things in mind,
we have taken into
careful consideration
how stuff looks and feels on
different screens and devices.
And so yes and no.
MATT GAUNT: I
remember an article
from Luke W. He actually
made the point if you tried
to change what kind of UI
you do based whether it was
on the touch screen or
a mouse and keyboard,
it actually became really
hard to do on the web.
That's-- I want to say
borderline impossible to do
perfectly.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Do Polymer, do
you touch anything like this?
Or is it just like, you're
still in the realm of web
and this is just the
state of the nation?
ROB DOBSON: No,
that's all right.
I don't know if we're
significantly changing anything
when you-- like our UI isn't
changing or anything like that
for elements drawn on like a
mobile screen or a desktop.
In practice, I mean when
I was pulling the contacts
app for instance, there wasn't
this thing where I was like,
oh there's this missing piece.
It didn't feel like there
was a missing piece.
I didn't feel like it
was a problem I actually
even ran into.
So I'd be interested
to see why Roman
was particularly
curious about this.
If there's something
specific that
is happening to him in his app
or his work where he's like,
hey, this is actually
a problem for me.
MATT GAUNT: That's a good point.
Roman, get on the Twitter.
So the next question is
from Marcus from Toronto.
Material design looks
slash feels great.
But there is a worry that
over use will result in apps
that all look and feel
the same, as happened
with other properties UI
libraries like jQuery UI
and Bootstrap.
What should devs slash designers
do to keep it feeling unique?
And this kind of
lends itself to,
if you were going to deviate
from the spec, when, how,
and what sort of parameters
should they stick to?
Or is it kind of like
deviate because you want to
and you feel that it's right.
ZACHARY GIBSON: I
think my opinion
on that is like some
of the best design
comes from a really
deep understanding
of a grid and a structure.
And then it breaks that.
That's when the
best things happen.
Because there's an awareness
of what exists and breaking
it can be really exciting.
PAUL LEWIS: Learn the rules
like a pro so you can break them
like an artist.
ZACHARY GIBSON:
There you go, yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Call him Pablo.
PAUL LEWIS: Bring
out Picasso-- again.
Nailed it.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Yeah.
And I think we're all sort
of true believers in that.
I think the floating
action button thing then
we have now is a good example of
like where were pushing people
to do innovative things with it.
And I think anyone
on L will start
to see like some of
that stuff happening.
And hopefully on
the web as well.
PAUL LEWIS: I do
think that there
is a-- like I said
before, I think
there are some of immutables.
There are good reasons why
a lot of those things exist,
the recommendations exist.
And there is a time
and place for branding.
But if I think if
you break rules,
a bit like with development.
I think you break them for good
reasons, and noble intentions,
and you have to be
able to justify.
It wasn't just, I
did it for the laugh.
I did it because I
wanted to feel special.
You do it because you
believe that you're
doing the right
thing by your user
by breaking that convention.
Otherwise I don't believe it's
a convention you should break.
Because you've now
forced the users
to relearn how to use your app
when they were happy using all
the other apps that did the
same thing in the same way.
ZACHARY GIBSON: Right.
I mean I don't want to discount
like patterns because patterns
are good.
And like my mom can go
from using her Android
phone to her iPad
and know where things
are because there's a
consistent structure.
JOSH ESTELLE: And there's a
lot of flexibility in the spec.
So the idea that you
have to break out
of the spec to make your app
look different is not true.
You can make your
app look different
and still completely
follow the spec.
There's a lot of room in there.
MATT GAUNT: So I'm afraid
we are out of time.
I'm very, very sorry.
But everyone give a round of
applause to the lovely panel.